way before tesla's full self driving
comma as open pilot
and gm super cruise google was hard at
work trying to develop a fully
autonomous car
starting in 2009 we all remember the
iconic videos of google's fleet of
toyota priuses
and lexuses making their way around test
courses and various neighborhoods
in the early 2010s though most people
weren't quite convinced of google's
ambitious time frames
the general consensus was that google
would likely win the race to autonomy
given their strong financial and
technological position
but over the past several years all the
hype regarding autonomy has gone to
tesla
despite entering the market six years
after google
on top of this valuations of google
self-driving car company
waymo have been slashed left and right
in 2018
morgan stanley valued waymo at a solid
175 billion dollars
however this would be slashed 100
billion dollars the very next year
and in early 2020 waymo would actually
complete a 3.2 billion dollar funding
round
that valued the company at just about 30
billion
so what happened to seemingly apparent
leader of self-driving technology
the google car project
[Music]
well taking a look at the history of the
google car project
it all started with a stanford professor
named sebastian thran
professor thran had been conducting
research regarding driverless vehicles
at stanford for quite some time and in
he and his team won the darpa grand
challenge
by creating a self-driving car named the
stanley robot car
in the challenge the car would drive 132
miles in desert autonomously
pulling in a cash price of 2 million
given this success
google would go on to hire professor
throne as a leader in google's ex
research lab
google's ex research lab is where google
works on their latest moonshot ideas
like google glass professor thrawn
didn't end up sticking around for that
long
but he did lay the foundation for
google's car project in 2009
professor throne would go on to found
the popular online educational
organization
udacity in 2011. anyways
going back to the google car project
google started off with the fleet of six
toyota priuses
and an audi tt and within just the first
year
the project would rack up over 140 000
autonomous miles
following this milestone in 2011 google
would switch over from toyota priuses to
23 lexus rx 450h
suvs after this transition however
we wouldn't hear very much from google
about the project for a couple of years
the next major update we received from
the company was in april
2014 when the company made a blog post
claiming that their vehicles
had made tremendous progress and that it
was capable of handling more edge cases
than
ever before soon after this progress
update
in may of 2014 google would unveil its
iconic mini car
with no brakes accelerator or steering
wheel
the car was only designed to go up to 25
miles per hour
thus it was determined that a lack of
user input shouldn't be too risky of a
move
despite their confidence one of the
lexus suvs would get into an accident in
february of 2016.
the physical damage from the crash
itself wasn't that big of a deal
as the accident occurred at 2 miles per
hour moreover
google's cars had gotten into several
similar accidents in the past
however the key difference between this
accident and all the ones that came
before
is that this was the first accident that
was caused by google's cars
nonetheless considering that it was just
a small accident
google continued to expand into arizona
in april 2016.
they specifically chose arizona in order
to get a better understanding of how the
heat
and dust in the state would affect the
car's sensors
during the same year google would go
through a corporate reshuffle
which led to the google car project
being spun into its own company called
waymo
but other than the name it's basically
the same thing
waymo would then go on to team up with
the fiat chrysler and
jaguar leading to the autonomous
pacifica minivans that we see
today and finally they would launch
their 100
autonomous ride sharing service in 2017.
over the past couple of years
google has been testing and launching
their rideshare service in a handful of
cities
including la a few cities in florida and
phoenix arizona
as of the start of 2020 google has a
fleet of
600 vehicles that have provided over 100
000 total ride shares since the start of
the program
more surprisingly in a portion of these
rides google didn't even use a safety
driver
looking forward google is aiming to add
another 62 thousand chrysler pacificas
to their fleet
along with 20 000 jaguar i-pace suvs
on top of this google is also working on
a more secretive project named husky
which is intended to tackle the trucking
and commercial delivery industries
as you can see it's not like google
stopped making progress
or ditched the project altogether or
anything like that
but then why is waymo's valuation
getting slashed
and the technology mostly getting
overlooked well
the first major issue for waymo is scale
if we've learned anything from tesla's
rough path over the last decade
it's that getting car production to
scale is an extremely difficult task
and whether google is looking to build
their own cars or partner with a car
manufacturer like chrysler
their expensive and complex leather
equipment does not make getting to skill
very easy the ceo of waymo john kraftsek
himself
has stated quote building a car is
difficult
but making a car that works well with
way more technology is
far more complicated unlike tesla and
openpilot
google has continued to embrace the use
of lidar
if you don't know what lidar is it's the
big raider on the top of the car
and though it was originally thought to
be crucial to the development of
autonomous vehicles
tesla and open pilot have largely proven
this to be false
by developing competitive self-driving
offerings using just regular cameras
and sensors now using lidar itself
is not a bad thing per se but
considering that it is generally a much
more expensive option
and that it is quite difficult to
install as the ceo described
getting to scale is unfortunately going
to be a nightmare for google
speaking of production skill google also
has another major skill problem
which is data collection skill google
owns all of the cars in their fleet
and that's only 600 cars this is
actually quite a lot considering that
all of the cars are privately owned
and financed by google which is likely
very expensive
but the problem is that their
competitors have found ways
around this limitation waymo reached 20
million autonomous miles at the start of
while tesla boasts a massive three
billion miles
even open pilot a small startup has been
able to reach 30 million self-driving
miles
by selling their technology publicly
google has insisted on keeping their
technology private
until they finish core development but
this has left them with a large data
shortfall
which is only getting bigger as we move
forward aside from this
waymo is battling another large
bottleneck which is their dependence on
hd maps
hd maps are basically a super high
definition scan
of roads and their surroundings and
these hd maps must be created
and constantly updated for way more cars
to work
this is because weimo's cars aren't
exactly
fully autonomous when a waymo car is on
the road
it also scans everything around it but
it doesn't make a decision based on what
it sees
instead it compares it with the original
scan done by the pilot car
in order to orient itself and determine
what exactly to do
in other words waymo's cars don't know
what to do
if they are not equipped with updated hd
maps in addition to being essentially
useless in unscanned areas
way more cars have many issues even in
scanned areas
for instance if you're venturing into a
new city that is supported by waymo
you have to download the relevant hd
maps before you leave
otherwise the car will resort to
downloading the massive hd maps
over cellular data which is sure to be
very expensive
as you can see google has some serious
scale and compatibility issues
when it comes to unscanned areas but
more importantly
they have a core issue which is a lack
of customers
when google originally set on creating
self-driving technology
their goal was to essentially create the
android of the self-driving space
and this is still their goal they are
delving into the rideshare space
but this is more of a method to perfect
the technology as opposed to their
actual business plan
ideally after finishing development they
want to license their technology to
other car manufacturers but there's one
major problem
who's going to buy ford is working on
their own self-driving car
gm is also working on their own
self-driving car
and this is the same case with mercedes
volkswagen
and toyota as well fiat chrysler may
decide to go along with google
but that's also not a guarantee moreover
even if these companies own endeavors
fail why would they choose google's
offerings
over the competition waymo's technology
is not only harder to install
and scale but it is handicapped by hd
maps
to make things even worse for waymo they
are not only likely to struggle
in gaining market share in the autonomy
licensing industry
but they are going to see fierce
competition within the rideshare market
as well
from tesla uber lyft and more
at the end of the day despite being the
pioneers of the self-driving industry
google's approach
and execution have significantly
dampened their chances of becoming the
leader in the industry
like originally anticipated this isn't
to say that they're going to go bankrupt
or shut down
it's very possible that they will go
into a sizeable niche
rideshare service within urban cores
however
at this point it doesn't seem like they
can break out to become much more than
that
but who knows maybe they have some
tricks up their slaves
do you guys think waymo has a chance
comment that down below
also drop a like if you guys love all of
this competition
and progress in the self-driving space
and of course
consider joining our discord community
to suggest future video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one